une multiplication des cas de thrombose
répertoriés le vaccin astrazeneca n'a
pas vraiment la cote dans l'hexagone
comme ici devant ce centre parisien qui
propose l'injection sans rendez vous
pour les membres de professions
prioritaires âgés d'au moins 55 ans pour
sylvie ce ne sera pas pour aujourd'hui
je pense avoir à yzeure je suis déjà
très inquiète sur le finder et la csn et
athénée call dont je rentre chez moi je
vais passer de ce vaccin c'est vraiment
par obligation que j'aime me faire
vacciner mais dans la crainte donc fait
ce qu'il nous rassure le plus en une
heure devant l'entrée quelques rares
candidats se présenteront ce dispositif
qui est mis en place est vraiment
quelque chose de formidable vraiment un
accueil formidable à une rapidité on est
même surpris qu'ils aient passé à ces
personnes parce que vraiment il ya peu
de fréquentation à l'intérieur plus tard
devant sept autres centres de
vaccination de seine saint denis
pourtant annonce ouvert une porte close
nous accueille suite à une erreur de
communication de l'académie de créteil
aucune vaccination du personnel
enseignant est organisé ce week end
quelques kilomètres plus loin cet
hôpital reçoit sans rendez vous pour le
vaccin astrazeneca
si personne n'acceptera de nous parler
face caméra on nous confiera que très
peu de personnes se sont présentées ce
matin là et le cac semble loin d'être
isolé plusieurs situations similaires
ont été rapportés dans la presse
prévisible selon le médecin un essayiste
laurent alexandre aujourd'hui quand les
médias sont mail avec quelques accidents
au mont panique l'opinion les gens ont
du mal à réaliser que on parle de
quelques accidents pour des dizaines de
millions de doses qui ont été injectés
donc ce sont des risques très faible on
a beaucoup moins de chances d'attraper
une thrombose en étant vaccinés par
l'astre à zenica qu'on en a des piqués
par une vipère ou d'être foudroyée
argenteuil dans le val d'oise toute
autre ambiance
alors aujourd'hui on a 340 rendez-vous
de vaccination les personnes qui ont
pris rendez-vous effectivement et avait
parfaitement conscience que c'était le
vaccin astrazeneca
elles sont reçues par un médecin avant
l'injection
donc si effectivement il ya des
questions les médecins sont là pour y
répondre et aujourd'hui toutes les
personnes qui avaient rendez vous se
sont fait vacciner mon fils m'a inscrit
hier soir
chenu cet après midi
ça s'est réglé comme une lettre à
musique je suis rentré on enregistre et
on m'a vacciné rien centimes alors
vraiment rien senti j'ai plus qu'à ce
compte da de la carte comme quoi j'ai
bien été vaccinées c'est très bien
organisé très bien orchestré les filles
sont très gentilles les infirmières sont
très gentilles c'est parfait outre la
mauvaise presse et les couacs
d'organisation astrazeneca risque aussi
de payer ces retards de livraison hier
le commissaire européen thierry breton a
déclaré qu'en raison des engagements non
tenus
l'europe pourrait ne pas renouveler ses
contrats avec le laboratoire
après le 30 juin